-I mentioned football is back,
and the first game of the season
was earlier tonight
right here on on NBC.
Tampa Bay Buccaneers
versus the Dallas Cowboys.
And as you know,
at the end of every season,
they give out awards like
Most Valuable Player.
But they also give out awards
at the start of the season.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"Tonight Show Superlatives."
-♪ "Tonight Show Superlatives" ♪
-Our first player from the Bucs
is Rob Gronkowski.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He was voted Most Likely to Yell
"Spring Break!" In September.
And you know, it's Spring Break
somewhere, man.
Next up from the Cowboys
is Leighton Vander Esch.
He was voted Most Likely To Have
"Neck Day" At The Gym.
It's neck day, bro.
Can you spot my --
-Spot my neck.
-Next up from the Bucs
is Vita Vea.
He was voted Most Likely
To Say His Own Name
Like The Little Caesar's Guy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Vita Vea.
-Vita Vea.
-Next up from the Cowboys
is CeeDee Lamb.
He was voted Most Likely
To Prank Calls
With The Fake Name
"Cee Deez Nuts."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, can I have
some pizza, please?
-Got caller I.D.
-Next up from the Bucs
is Grant Stuard.
He was voted Most Likely
To Do A Touchdown Dance
To Kenny G.'s "Songbird."
[ Band plays
Kenny G.'s "Songbird" ]
♪♪
Next up from the Cowboys
is DeMarcus Lawrence.
He was voted Most Likely To Say
"You Better Watch Out, I'm
Wearing My Football Glasses."
[ Applause ]
Next up from the Cowboys
is Connor Williams.
He was voted Most Likely
To Reply, "I Didn't Eat
Any Gummies" To Any Question
You Ask Him.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
Next up from the Bucs,
we have Leonard Fournette.
He was voted Most Likely
To Have A Magnetic Beard.
[ Laughter ]
Don't sneeze. Don't sneeze.
And finally,
we have the quarterback
of the Bucs, Tom Brady.
He was voted Most Likely To Lose
A Super Bowl Ring And Say,
"Eh, I'll Get A New One."
There you go --
there's your NFL superlatives.